in your interactions with your employees
your direct reports if you've got a
30-minute stand-up take the first 10
minutes and talk and share and just ask
questions how are you what's going on
you know and pay attention if you're on
a zoom call with somebody
if you've got a cat that's making lots
of noise or a dog or you've got a child
doing cartwheels in the background take
some time to talk about that find out
what's going on in the person's life in
that moment
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
hello hello and welcome to another
episode of 20-minute leaders
meet rob volpe the ceo of ignite 360.
rob is an astute observer of life and a
master storyteller who brings empathy
and compassion to the human experience
as ceo of ignite 360 he leads a team of
insights strategy and creative
professionals serving the world's
leading brands across a range of
industries
he is the author of tell me more about
that solving the empathy crisis one
conversation at a time
as a thought leader in the role of
empathy and marketing in the workplace
he is a contributor to entrepreneurs
leadership network and frequently speaks
on the topic at conferences corporations
colleges podcasts and with the media he
is a graduate of syracuse university's
s.i newhouse school of public
communications and lives in san
francisco with his husband and three
cats
any chance that i get to talk about
empathy and talk about how
we can be better as humans
and better as as companies and do better
for the world i'm in and so i appreciate
you taking these 20 minutes to speak
with me today the ceo of and chief
catalyst speaker and empathy activist of
ignite 360 and i'm excited to hear this
firm and what you're doing but i'm i'm
even more excited to understand
the way you think and your internal
convictions about the workforce and
about empathy and discussions and and
the books you've written and so a lot of
a lot for us to unpack rob and thank you
very very much for being here uh yeah
absolutely happy to do it um probably a
lot to unpack in 20 minutes but let's
dive in
we'll do our best and and we'll start
off uh
simple and hard empathy what brings you
to discuss empathy on a daily basis
internally and externally sure
so always been a superpower of mine
since the time i was a kid growing up
got teased and bullied and i found
empathy was the thing that i was able to
use to navigate through school and
survive so it became a survival
technique when i was a child
and then as an adult there was i think
the big transition point for me that
really led us to to where we are today
uh there was a study that came out of
the university of michigan that found
they were tracking um the
empathy ability of college students
starting in 1979 all the way through
2009 and they looked at 76 different
universities and they found that at the
at about 2000 2001 there was a 40
percent decline in empathy skills the
ability to see the point of view of
somebody else compared to college
students of those previous decades and
that number never moved back up so it
wasn't a 911 induced blip or or
something from the economy at that
moment
it was a crisis uh situation in in my
mind and i remember study came out in
2010 i was in an airport it was on cnn
you could see the little ticker scroll
going by and i was like oh my god this
is huge because if you were in college
in 2001
that meant by 2010 you were about 30
years old you were already in the
workforce you were possibly a manager or
a leader and if you didn't have enough
empathy if your your empathy muscles
weren't strong enough you weren't going
to be contributing and and helping in
the fullest possible way to uh that your
company's success to the success of
people that you're managing to
innovation all the things that that
empathy enables
and so
because i worked in marketing research
and still do that's what ignite 360 does
we study human behavior and we
understand how people think and feel and
our job is to build empathetic
connections between our clients and
their consumers and oftentimes yeah with
startups it's the founders often
identified a problem and that might even
be a problem that they've had themselves
and they're working to solve that
situation
but with a larger corporation and as as
companies scale and grow you bring other
people in they don't have that
connection to the original root problem
that that's what got the company started
so it's really important for clients to
be able to dismantle their judgment and
to actually connect and understand their
consumer but we were finding there was a
lot of barriers getting in the way of
empathy probably because of this empathy
crisis that's been going on and so we
set out to understand like okay
what do we do what are the barriers that
get in the way how do people actually
overcome
that so they can get to a point of
empathy and that's where we developed
what we call the five steps to empathy
which are those things that in the
moment that you're engaging with
somebody that you need to do in order to
connect with them and and have cognitive
empathy
and so if you're looking back for a
second to understand your superpower
better you're mentioning the way that
you just you know the the you this was
your survival technique now just to be
clear you know your empathy was towards
the people that were bullying you the
people that were teasing you your
friends yeah yeah it was yes all of the
above but it was really towards the
people that were bullying me i was
trying to understand where they were
coming from
i couldn't figure out at that point in
time
why they were treating me that way but i
could hear more about their own lives
and try to connect with them
and show that i understood them and i
understood who they were
so that hopefully if a rumor got started
or somebody got agitated wanted to try
to beat me up or something
they'd go well no he's a good guy don't
don't you know they wouldn't engage or
might help dissuade the situation so it
made life a bit easier for me at the
time and helped me navigate
well so if we're looking today at the
you know the workforce and i'm looking
at you know startups across the board
and you're coming and saying you know
what we you know we've been having you
know these problems that over
generations our levels of empathy have
declined and this is a
obviously and and non-controversially an
important skill for us as as leaders and
as business people and and colleagues
what what is missing why do you think
today you were looking at the workforce
why are we lacking empathy in what we're
doing why is it i mean so many different
factors are going into it i i refer to
it as the unintended consequences of
good intentions over the years so
um societally if you look at the way you
know going back into the mid 90s the way
kids were being raised
and being over scheduled or being kept
really busy
either because it was providing
that's why cat domino she has a lot to
say about empathy
i love it i i usually have my dog
barking where i wish i had him right
here with me yeah she is so she's she my
husband that now has her entertained
um but um
there's a lot of things that that lead
into it so the way kids were being
raised whether they were being over
scheduled for child care reasons or
because the parents wanted their kids to
have us a chance to get into a good
college and needed to build the resume
so
all of that was taking away from kids
ability to be bored and to go into
imaginative play i mean it you know
right so when mom used to say or your
dad would say go in the backyard and
play or go up to your room and find
something to do
that typically what would happen you
would get into an imaginative play space
whether you're playing with action
figures or dolls or you're playing um
superheroes or cops and robbers whatever
you're playing in the backyard
that all requires empathy and that's
building the skill of empathy so that
got diminished it didn't go away
completely but it got diminished and
then you have uh the the
images that we were seeing in the media
and the combativeness that was starting
to come up and the winner takes all
in social media or not social media in
reality tv
um which again started to really explode
around uh the late 90s early 2000s and
also in scripted television and it
became about the anti-hero and it became
so those that was was contributing to it
um you also had then our relationship to
technology technology is a one-way you
know you and the device you and the
screen rather than you and another
person having a meaningful conversation
and then there's social media and i'm
not going to go too far into that most
people are aware of social media's
ability to
really sell social medias about
validating and self-worth and making us
feel better about ourselves
rather than about how we connect with
other people
um globalization has come into play
people are suddenly faced with people
that are other that we hadn't before and
then in the workplace we have decades
upon decades of
patriarchal
non-emotional management processes that
have been taught through business
schools and just through learning and
being passed down from
you know manager to employee
on and on and on and it's sad that
there's no room for empathy in the
workplace and it's really just been with
the pandemic one of the positives of the
pandemic suddenly people are like no
wait a minute i want something different
and i need something different
so so going based off of that you know
we're looking at a business at the end
i'm looking at you know people running
startups there's so many different
issues with running a startup and so
many different complexities
i want to understand why should one of
their
why should one of their focuses be on
empathy you know why should my friend
was running a company and is focused on
hiring and firing and and selling to new
customers and developing etc why should
he or she bring empathy to one of the
top things that they should be concerned
with in their day-to-day of the company
culture
a great question a lot of leaders are
asking that whether they're at startups
or at larger you know fortune 100
companies and and the reasons there's a
lot of data that's out there studies
over the last year have found you know
90 of gen z are
more likely to stay at a company where
they have empathetic leadership um
there's also fact data that uh three
quarters of employees feel engaged in
their jobs when they've got highly
empathetic managers
um 86 of employees are able to manage
demands of work and personal life when
they've got an empathetic leader
um
61 of employees are able to be
innovative at work when they have an
empathetic leader compared to only 13
if they don't have an empathetic leader
so
i mean and those are just a few data
points from some of the different
studies that have been coming out in the
last year
there's a lot of benefit to having to
being empathetic and we're not talking
about
emotional empathy i'm talking about
cognitive empathy and that that's
there's a lot of
misconceptions and fear
around empathy that people have and and
so what i try to myth bust um in my book
and then in in conversations like this
is hey
there's cognitive empathy which is the
perspective taking and then there's
emotional empathy and the emotional
empathy is the feeling the feelings of
somebody else
i don't ask people to get to a place of
emotional empathy there's a lot of
things that i think get in people's way
um and it's also reserved for the people
that are closest to you but cognitive
empathy seeing somebody else's
perspective
that's what we use in our day-to-day
that's what we use in business if you're
sitting at the negotiating table
wouldn't you benefit from understanding
what you the person sitting across the
table from you it needs or wants so that
you can either use that in your
negotiation and your persuasion or
understand what you might have to do to
get to that halfway point or get to that
that place of agreement
uh to close your deal fascinating i i
love the distinction between the
emotional empathy and the cognitive
empathy
and i think that sometimes um you know
we
we aim to obviously i think every person
wants to have more empathy but sometimes
it feels so distant and so complicated
and say okay but i'm not i'm not
emotionally attached here so what's
wrong and what is why can't i you know
why can't i and but understanding that
there's different levels and that you're
able to still
you know
have this cognitive empathy and be able
to listen and understand the other's
opinion
you can still get you know 80 of the
value and the way that you interact with
them there so more tangibly now rob for
looking at companies organizations
teams how how can we actually make it
better what are some actual things that
we can do to be better leaders be better
colleagues have more empathy in the
workforce yeah i think about it from the
perspective of you know
as a leader or founder or investor
you're always like keep the foot on the
gas go go go go go
and
you don't take your foot off the gas but
you might sort of adjust your carburetor
and the mix that is going in of how much
fuel and oxygen are coming into the
catalytic converter
which someday that's going to be a
really ancient analogy that i'm not
going to be able to use but
um as we move towards battery operated
and then solar and things however for
now it still works um
you know it's taking some time one of
the the simplest things that i counsel
people to do
is in
in your interactions with your employees
your direct reports if you've got a 30
minute stand up take the first 10
minutes and talk and share and just ask
questions how are you what's going on
you know and pay attention if you're on
a zoom call with somebody
if you've got a cat that's making lots
of noise or a dog or you've got a child
doing cartwheels in the background take
some time to talk about that find out
what's going on in the person's life in
that moment
that's all showing empathy and be able
to say back to them i can imagine how
you feel or i can see your point of view
i can see where that would be difficult
to be trying to do a podcast and have a
cat meowing you know right at your foot
wanting your attention away from the
other thing that you're trying to do
that creates an empathetic moment
and that makes me that if i'm on the
recipient
receiving side of that like when you
when that event happened and you said oh
yeah i've got a dog and you know if my
dog were here i'd be doing this that
made us you had empathy with me you
understood what i was going through
which made me feel safer and like okay
i'm not going to freak out about that
it's all right
let's go ahead and move through
um and it's it's doing things like that
with your employees with everybody in
your organization it's leaders finding a
place of vulnerability and being
comfortable sharing
some of their own perspective and
feelings beyond the corporate script um
that we felt like we we've had to follow
for the last 20 30 40 years
be a little more honest be a little more
human
talk about how you know the last two
years has have been affecting you um and
on a personal level i mean there's
obviously all the company things that
people are seeing but then how are you
dealing with that and and people you'd
be surprised people want to support
their leader if they're if they're
really bought into the organization
they might give you empathy back in
return and that actually feels really
good
i love that
rob how you know i understand you know
the way your journey and your personal
conviction and you know a lot of people
care a lot about empathy and care a lot
about how do we make things better in
this regard where you're really
dedicating your career to this well
how how does that work in your
day-to-day how do you actually make make
a career
with helping people be more empathetic
well i've i've created an organization
that you know specializes in
helping people empathetically understand
human behavior understand their
customers
and we have as we developed the five
steps we recognized that there was an
opportunity for us to put it into
everything that we do so we've developed
training programs uh around empathy we
um bring it into before we go out into
the field on any research project we
talk about the five steps and help our
clients
have awareness of it and and and just
that little act spending five minutes
talking about empathy i've had
um brand managers marketers come out of
a research session and say to me wow i
was really having trouble hearing what
that person was saying until i realized
that i had judgment and i needed to
dismantle my judgment and when i did
it opened up all these new insights that
i hadn't been listening to
um and when you hear those those success
stories when we're able to actually make
that connection when we're able to use
our storytelling abilities to really
bridge that gap whether it's at the
c-suite or at the factory floor
making uh people realize this is why i'm
doing this this is who i'm making these
products for that's a gift back for us
and i think just inspires us to to do
even even better
um and and i personally i think there's
an opportunity for us to make the world
a better place and and leave a better
world than what we're we've found and
are living through and if empathy is my
way of doing that i'm i'm all for it
i i love how much i believe you it's i
can feel it in your voice i can feel it
in your tone and and i can feel it in in
the personal journey that you shared
with me and i really appreciate it rob
and it leaves me with a little bit more
inspiration
uh that you know the way that i'm going
to be interacting
and not just with my teammates
employees leaders etc but but also with
you know people in general and be more
empathetic and it sounds like it'll also
you know be besides making me a better
person for them it also makes me a
better person for me and so i'm gonna
take that with me and rob thank you very
very much i appreciate your time and
your energy and stay safe thank you
michael appreciate the time